[Music]
all right it is time to get this show
started it's time to dive into the
treacherous world of Crusader Kings 3
with a fresh look at live gameplay from
our newest friend strategy game please
give a warm welcome which will happily
accept over the Internet to game
designer aleksandr owner and community
developer rod del Ruth
hi Paula thanks for having us I welcome
thank you so you just dropped some major
news for Crusader Kings the game will be
released on September 1st yes which is
literally around the corner and
pre-orders are alive right now
rod how has the reception in the
community been so far it's been so good
people are really appreciating the dev
Diaries that we're putting forward we
have fans that have loved seeing the new
religious system that we have and also
the lifestyle system that adds to you
know just that little extra layer of RPG
so it's been pretty good we're super
happy good and Alex how is the mood in
the dev team right now oh it's fantastic
the team has been working really really
hard and of course it's both frightening
and exciting to get feedback from our
fans like this we love the game and we
love all the feedback we're getting and
we're counting down the hours to
September 1st wonderful rod tell us a
little bit about what you have prepared
for us today yeah absolutely so we're
gonna start with one of the most
interesting starting position in ck3
which is gonna be in Spain essentially
what we want to showcase here is the
various decision that are open to you
even before you press play and start
playing it's like taking a look at the
various challenges that you are facing
before you start the game oh well let's
dive in some later all right
the year is thousand sixty-six and we
are located in northern Spain of course
it's not Spain yet and it won't be for
another four hundred years unless we
expedite the process northern Spain is
divided into a number of Catholic
kingdoms that stand against the powerful
Moorish realms of the south
in northwestern Iberia we have three
kingdoms ruled by three brothers we have
galicia we have just still and us in
leon one new feature in to say the Kings
three is the issues widget at the top
and if we click it we can see that we
are in line to inherit both galicia and
just deal and see this is what makes
this starting position super interesting
we are playing as leon and the only
thing that is standing between us and
the throne of Ganesha is or caste and
brother and we need to attack him first
before rushing for galicia if we look at
the map we can see that galicia is the
one that is most open to moorish attacks
you're still in leon both have southern
mountains that provide a very defensible
advantage and if we compare our
mistresses we can clearly see that
Castile is the biggest army while we
have a middling army and the young the
young king of Galicia has the smallest
army none of us really have an edge over
the other but we might be able to find
an ally to support us and in Crusader
Kings this might mean marriage right
absolutely Paola marriage is super keen
Crusader Kings free if you don't have a
marriage you don't have any allies and I
think we should take a look at the
various our Berrian countries that we
have around us and I think an arrogant
princess would do just fine
indeed this Aragon is princess will get
us their armies on our side next let's
take a look at our King so all
characters in stick III have five
different skills and we can see here
that King Alfonso is very good at
intrigue which means that he can plot
and scheme very effectively and if we
appoint a skilled spy master to support
our schemes and we get a spouse that
enhances our intrigue we can become even
better and to top it all off we will
pick a lifestyle that really accentuates
this focus on scheming
we will take the skullduggery focus yeah
absolutely and it's key here to lean to
him intrigue and why is that because
like Alex was mentioning we have evenly
matched forces against caste so we
should really lean into that intrigue
and start a murder plot to get rid of
the brother okay so the plan is to kill
the brother here Alex are we moving
forward with this in deed we're going to
try and murder our brother as you can
see we have a 50% chance of succeeding
and if we are lucky we can even find
more agents in the court of our targets
that might be convinced by a slight
bribe yeah and that's the cool thing
with Crusader Kings right if you're
trying to plot a murder against someone
and you don't have enough power to
succeed you can bribe people but you
also have a special perk in the intrigue
lifestyle with the net which essentially
allows you to find secret and dirt on
people in your court and then force them
to join your plot so many different
options but unfortunately we're running
out of time here but Alex how do you
think that this this story will play out
oh there are so many unanswered
questions will our plot plot against our
Castilian brothers succeed will we gain
Galicia before Galicia manages to
produce a legitimate heir will we be
able to leverage the armies from Castile
and Aragon to take over Galatea in time
can we contain all of this familial
treason before we have to fight external
enemies there are millions of ways for
this to play out yeah I guess we'll have
to wait a little bit longer but thank
you so much for taking us through thank
you but of the drama that you can expect
in Crusader Kings 3 due to be released
on September 1st and available for
pre-order now well betrayal
assassination treason kind of feels like
we're having a paradox already yeah yeah
I agree went down the dark path pretty
fast there good but I guess that the
next game that we have lined up is not
gonna this
point us either I mean building a crime
Empire in the 1920s Chi cago it's not
something that you're gonna get away
with without bribing a few cops breaking
a few alliances maybe cutting some
questionable deals on the black market
what do you think underhanded tactics
politics taking over the city these are
all things that are very close to where
my heart once was next up is Empire of
sin